i don't even know if you remember but we
actually we didn't i don't know if we
met that officially but i know we were
both at the event i don't know if it was
in canada or something i don't know but
i got to hear you sing and you are
stunningly gorgeous singer you're you're
weird no that's so crazy
you're so funny this isn't even in the
script i just wanted to say that
my first concert i ever went to in my
life oh really
yeah you were young how old were you i
had to be
i had to be seven or eight and it was me
and my mom and my sisters
and i still have the poster from your
concert uh it was
the breakaway days which i still listen
to when i'm on airplanes and i cry so
it's great um but yeah you're just such
a such an inspiration to me
oh that's so kind i just wanted to tell
you i was like i don't even know if you
remember
we were
did we split a bathroom that's not good
i don't know if we did or not but i kept
i feel like we might have because i was
worried i was like what if i have to go
to like the bathroom sometimes get
two sticks and you can hear like if i
was doing my warm-up
exactly all the fingers warm up in the
bathroom so i'm like well i can't wait
did i hear you doing your warm-ups
in the back probably did and i'm very
sorry but why would you be sorry
it's so funny i'm a total choir nerd
yeah amazing i love that if i don't warm
up it goes away so